what is happening there reject nation
we're going to watch today
honest trailers for kosher versus
king kong which by the way i re-watched
uh the other day
at home was it's meant to be seen i
gotta say man i love the hell out of
this movie
i really do i liked it eve i liked it
more the second time i watched
it oh yeah i found myself wanting to
write a video essay on it oh
yeah so whatever i finally branch out
into video essays
yeah dude godzilla versus kong i'll
start telling you guys
why this movie is more brilliant than
you ever realize it is
but in the meantime let's watch honest
trailers make fun of it
yeah sure
[Music]
the following trailer is rated s for
spoilers
i mean you can probably tell from the
title that godzilla fights king kong but
we tell you who wins
if that sort of thing matters to you
sean bailey
[Music]
in a year where everyone realized we're
at the mercy of nature
the world will sublimate that anxiety
into watching a giant monkey
fight a giant lizard in a perfectly
timed release
before we snap and punch and or kiss the
mailman
i'm scared to see this in a theater not
because of the virus i've just
completely forgotten how to interact
with people
godzilla
you've been moderately pleased by all
the legendary contributing
now tune in for another bad sober good
with a buzz installment
of the sloppiest franchise running where
character and timeline continuity is
more of a suggestion
featuring characters they forgot to
mention were related i do got to say oh
i guess we're doing the pause method
here
yeah it's all good i do gotta say that
sarah zawa one is probably the most
disappointing factor to me i
love syrizaba yeah am i saying his name
right whatever we know tell me watch man
how do you pronounce this japanese
listen to me i love ken watanabe in the
first movie
a lot he brings so much richness to the
character and then in king of the
monsters while he gets a great sacrifice
moment i was kind of upset by the fact
how so much of what kyle
chandler's leading position and
direction and guidance
i was like well this should have just
been ken watson nobody's yeah yeah
absolutely and it feels like that whole
movie can watch nami just gets sidelined
in here i'm like well you got his son
doesn't he makes sense why his son's an
ape
what the hell is going on
characters they forgot to mention
entirely and characters who forgot they
discovered the earth was hollow in the
last movie
the vortex was a tunnel into the hollow
earth it doesn't matter
absolutely no one watching gives a sh
about any of it
now make with the monkey bites yes
ah that's the stuff meet the humans of
the monster verse
because i had to so now you do too
they're just here to yell at what's
going on
even though there's no way any of them
could possibly know that information
this is why godzilla attacked the apex
facility they're trying to replace him
it's the axe it's drawing radiation from
the core like it's charging
yeah it could be a sciatic interface
it's just a little
man how did you know that you know how i
would describe the humans in this movie
you know when you like go to
universal studios for like one of those
3d rides and then you're waiting in line
and then they have like they have the
videos
you're like this is not all that
interesting or entertaining but it'll do
in the meantime till we go on the ride
yeah you know it's novel that dwayne
johnson showed up to shoot this intro
even though it doesn't look like he
actually wants to shoot it
that is exactly how i felt oh that's
what they are
they're the filler while you're waiting
bored in line yeah yeah
yeah between roller coasters but don't
worry
they all have a back story whether it's
their dead wife
she was my rocker my truth dead brother
what really went wrong on your brother's
mission
dead mom or screw it dead everyone
when the storm took over the island it
wiped out the native people
as they carry on the monsterverse
tradition of hiring great actors
then making them say stuff like this
with a straight face right now
godzilla's out there and he's hurting
people and we don't know why
bridge has the overly dramatic dialogue
it's way funnier than the intentional
comedy of the film
as you follow along that counter line
was hilarious yeah that was funny
the podcaster something bad i know god
is a ridiculous stroke
corporate conspiracy brian tyree henry
branson raised his way through the
sharpest conspiracy theory jokes of
2007.
the illuminati running shadow economy is
ought to find a hidden colony for the
elite
water they put fluoride in it and millie
bobby brown returns as his kaiju and
easy to manipulate plus this boy is also
there
in this goofy subplot that could be
completely cut without anyone noticing
you only need one group of humans to
follow in these movies okay everyone
else is there to either be squished and
or cheer when godzilla destroys
their home what i'll say
too though what i appreciate about the
rewatch was oh i kind of like the
evolution of the fact that millie bobby
brown
has a friend now like she's a very just
lonely introverted
girl and king of the monsters and she's
a demonstration that she's grown she has
a person she can really confide in be
her best friend the issue that happens
is like too many avatars at once for
the audience to live through when you
got julian dennison and brian tyree
henry when it felt like
a lot of the quirky manic behavior
aspects should have just been given to
one
of them yeah not both julian dennison
and brian tyree henry that's when it
becomes like too much for example that
line with it's a robot godzilla
no it's mecca godzilla it was that
moment when it hit me of
at this point it should have just been
one of them who has this kind of
personality and one of them just should
have said it's mechagodzilla
yeah there's a character and then the
mini version of the character yeah
then they get and they're sort of like
they sort of build a dynamic
out of that but yeah at the same time
there's not enough time and development
put in that to actually have it grow so
then it just becomes this weird
little quirk of the movie and also you
know i think you needed to get to the
mechagodzilla
part and yeah the podcast thing is oh no
i you're not gonna get tired of that
trophy are there any
like conspiracy pot like like podcasts
where they have no ads
just but they're popular and growing and
i don't know about any of those podcasts
there's gotta be one there's gotta be
this one right yeah with a title like
godzilla
versus kong they better deliver on the
fights as they pit the titular titans
against each other
no less than three times hell yeah
godzilla wins two out of three because i
mean come on
look at the guy hell yeah he does
yes kong spends more time on his back
than riley reed
but the film will do everything in its
power to make your root for the big
hairy boy
he's friends with children he loves
snacks and he's got thor zacks
i mean come on the only endearing thing
godzilla does is destroy part of florida
but no versus movie would be complete
without them joining forces at the end
oh you see
but that's what i liked about what they
did with kong what is the story we know
of king kong king of skull island and
then he's brought over here against his
own
will and then he's kind of just this
slave he's made into a show
yeah in america in the king kong story
and then that's kind of what they're
doing here he's king of skull island and
kong skull island then he's brought over
here and he's just
used he's just a slave throughout this
whole movie this
puppet for us yeah and he wants no part
of any of this help us discover
things bring us elements we have no
business using so i thought it was kind
of neat to go oh they aren't
they're doing their own like reinvention
of the king kong story but meshing it in
with
with him versing godzilla instead of it
being this entertainment thing where you
buy tickets at a theater for you
why would we bring him over here today
it wouldn't be for entertainment it
would be for
for money to kill something bigger
no versus movie would be complete
without them joining forces at the end
against a surprise third fighter what
the hell is that
what the hell is that what god's name is
mega godzilla
let's make a godzilla a giant jaeger
created to fight godzilla
until he loses human control and fights
godzilla
causing the two bees to team up against
this
yeah poor hong kong
that is a great fight though man damn
these are
both flats are great no wonder this
movie is huge in china so see it on the
biggest screen you can
which for most of us right now is our
phone even though it's probably best
suited for one of those theme park rides
with moving seats
hey it's just talking about that shot
right there yeah
yeah absolutely that may not be the most
intelligent thing you could be watching
but you know what neither are we and we
spoke this movie into existence back in
2014
from the company who has the rights to
godzilla king kong
and pacific rim so please please please
do a crossover where they all fight each
other and stuff
you're welcome story there's all you got
i get knocked down
but i get up again reptile wins
for each other on today's show we're
going to reveal the horrible truth
but first i'd like to tell you about
squarespace
rebecca heidi ho the chris hemsworth of
the brothers skarsgard
i like titan's punch out
okay not trying to kink shane but why
are all these monsters always trying to
spit in each other's mouths yeah that's
not a thing real animals do
they learn this from watching people
that's gross
whatever i'm so bad but i don't think i
can spare
the moisture i was hiding under your
porch
because i love you at least they aren't
making a karen in the last manager movie
yet
i'm tired of these mother boxer snakes
and this mother boxes plane
now good work bailey and the writers of
honest trailers i'll add this about
performances though something that
really dawned on me when we were
watching it when i was watching last
time alexander skarsgard i like a lot in
this movie
it's a very biased opinion let's say it
was my first time watching alexander
skarsgard in this movie i might not
care that much i'll be like yeah he's
good he's fine i like it a lot because
i'm so used to seeing him playing tough
people
yeah like he's plays tough people
constantly yeah
i've seen people love tough buff people
and i've seen it so many times and he's
a great actor
here i thought he's so natural if this
was my first time watching him in this
movie i would have assumed this is the
kind of roles he always plays
yeah yeah he borrows some of his
brother's sleepiness
you know i'm saying he's so natural in
it that
it's kind of easy to overlook like damn
you know he
actually he plays the shy awkward
science guy
in a way that doesn't feel forced ever
like yeah he feels very natural how he
does it he
is so human and how he how he plays it i
think you could only appreciate
it truly if you've seen other alexander
skarsgard movies
you know watch some true blood and tell
me that's not the exact same character
that's what i mean
all right guys well honest trailers this
was fun fun to be back here
godzilla vs kong what do you think leave
your thoughts down below
the like button you know what to do
tyler haig tyler
my man if there was someone at our
patreon
if there was a god kong or
kongzilla if they were to make that
it would be you you have the kong
presence the sympathetic expressions
the fire breathing ferocity plus your
head is really small compared to the
rest of you
that's mean don't make fun of him no i
didn't mean that tyler
he has a great head you have a great use
of sexy the size of his head i love your
head matter of fact that was the first
thing i know is about time
streamlining it was like damn what a
head this guy's dude
this guy's head i wish i had a head like
this head i know i would i would
take a cranial regime put it above my
bed
i would scalp you and i would cherish it
i would do it out of respect tyler
we're scalping you i hope you're
grateful
when you see your head put on display
on the wall of my mother's bed oh there
yeah she would love that she loves her
thing she
loves she's good she doesn't like
getting uh anything
but she loves actually you know what i'm
getting she's playing the real
thing where's the shout out starting
thank you for your love and support
tyler